this right here is the logitech combo
touch keyboard case and it's the best
thing that has ever happened to this
ipad the 10.2 inch 7th generation budget
ipad but not only this ipad there's an
identical version of this keyboard case
for both the 10.5 inch ipad air and the
10.5 inch pro so if you have one of
those ipads this review is also for you
and i'll drop some links down in the
description to the correct version of
this keyboard for each of those ipads
now the reason i said that it's the best
thing ever is because it has something
that you can't get on any other case as
of right now a built-in trackpad that
works together with apple's new cursor
support to basically turn this ipad into
a laptop replacement but before i get
into my thoughts on how good this
keyboard case is in terms of the
functionality of the trackpad and the
keyboard let's start off with the
details the case comes in two parts the
keyboard part in the case itself on the
exterior and the inside of the keyboard
it has this really nice woven fabric
like texture that seems to be made out
of plastic so it should be fairly stain
resistant the keyboard portion can
actually connect by itself without the
case by simply bringing it close to the
smart connector the magnets will snap it
into place and it holds on pretty well
and then when you fold the keyboard over
the ipad's display there are more
magnets inside of the ipad that also
hold it into place so you get a nice and
slim keyboard folio but the downside is
that there's no kickstand to hold the
ipad upright and that's where the case
portion comes in with the case on it
becomes a lot more thick but after using
it over the weekend it's actually not
that bad considering everything you're
getting with it first off the built-in
kickstand is really solid and i'm very
impressed with how well logitech
balanced it with it being very easy to
adjust and very sturdy at the same time
this gives you a really nice variety of
viewing angles you could set it almost
90 degrees upright or you can lay it
down flat point it up towards the
ceiling or you can even fold it all the
way down and lay it flat on the table
and at that point you can take off the
keyboard case and just have it in tablet
mode which is perfect for using the
apple pencil and then again you can prop
it up using the kickstand so you can
watch a movie without having the
keyboard in the way and thanks to the
extra thickness you're getting an
extremely solid case the sides are made
out of a really solid rubber material so
you should get great drop protection
without worrying about it cracking and
you can see how thick this rubber is by
looking at any of the cutout holes now
that is a durable case the case also
comes with a little sleeve on the top
for the apple pencil so i'm really happy
that the only compromise of this case is
that it's just a bit thick and i'd
rather have that instead of having a
case that isn't very durable or has a
crappy kickstand that isn't solid so
props to logitech for that now moving on
to the keyboard portion when you first
connect this keyboard you'll be asked to
download the logitech control app within
the app you can adjust the duration that
the keyword backlighting will stay on
and the speed at which it fades off and
i'd highly recommend everyone to keep
the update notifications toggle enabled
so that you can keep the firmware up to
date now before we talk about the
quality of the keyboard let's first talk
about the trackpad since they have to
keep it slim and there's a limited
amount of power that can go through that
smart connector this case gets a
traditional trackpad which isn't on the
same level as the force touch motorized
one that comes in a macbook so that
means that you get a diving board design
meaning that it's hard to click near the
top and very easy near the bottom that's
really my only complaint about it since
it feels like you really have to push
down sometimes to click but thankfully
you can go into the settings then
general trackpad and you can enable tap
to click which i fully recommend
everyone to use alongside that setting
you can adjust the tracking speed or
toggle the natural scrolling setting if
it seems like your swipes on the
trackpad feel reversed and finally
there's the two-finger secondary click
setting which is extremely important to
me because you no longer have to tap
hold and wait for additional options to
show up you simply use two fingers to
tap and it happens instantly so this
trackpad becomes incredibly useful when
you want to do things like drag and drop
for example just simply click and hold
on an image in the files app and drag it
over into google drive while in split
view mode now one of the features that i
don't like about the new cursor support
is how the cursor morphs into various
buttons as you hover over them now there
is a way to turn this off but only if
you have a mouse connected but what a
lot of people don't know including a lot
of the early reviewers is that you can
actually hook up a mouse just one time
to change the settings and then when you
disconnect it those settings will be
saved for the trackpad on this keyboard
case so as you can see i've connected a
bluetooth mouse and now when i go into
the accessibility settings i have a new
pointer control page
there i can adjust various things like
increasing the contrast
the color
the size of the pointer i can increase
how long it takes for the pointer to
hide after inactivity i can turn off
trackpad inertia which i find extremely
annoying since the cursor keeps moving
after you stop touching the trackpad
which can lead to inaccuracy i can
increase the speed of scrolling for
things like scrolling up and down on a
website and finally i can turn off the
pointer animations feature that i
dislike so much now when i go to the
home page the cursor no longer morphs
into buttons so it feels a lot more like
a traditional cursor and the best part
is that when you disconnect your mouse
and put it away all of those changes are
saved and it works perfectly on the
trackpad now perhaps the most important
thing that you need to learn about the
trackpad is the gestures and once you
get the hang of them your productivity
will go through the roof of course you
can use two fingers to swipe left and
right or up and down when on the home
screen swipe down with two fingers to
access spotlight search when viewing a
photo use two fingers and pinch to zoom
in and then spread them to zoom out or
alternatively you can double tap on any
section you want to zoom into use three
fingers and swipe left and right on the
trackpad to switch between recent apps
use three fingers and swipe up to get to
the home screen or you can do the same
thing but don't lift your three fingers
off the track pad to quickly get to the
app switcher now moving on to the
keyboard what's great about it is that
you get a row of function keys at the
top in the top left corner you get an
escape key which will bring you to the
home screen from any app or you can
double click it to get the app switcher
then you have your brightness keys which
are so much more convenient compared to
the control center you also have a
keyboard button just in case you want to
pull up the on-screen keyboard then
there's a spotlight search button which
you can use within any app which is
great because usually you have to go to
the home screen first to use it then you
have your backlight brightness keys with
five different settings from completely
off to surprisingly bright so i
absolutely love this feature for using
it at night then you also have your
media keys including mute and volume
buttons and finally the lock key at the
end which is more convenient than
reaching up and hitting the power button
and if you hold it down you can actually
power off your ipad on the bottom row
you get the same control option and
command keys that you get on a macbook
and you even get an additional globe key
that you can use to instantly bring up
emojis or you can tap it again to
quickly switch between languages and the
best part about the keyboard is that it
supports all of the same shortcuts you
have on a macbook for example command h
brings you to the home screen command
tab shows a list of all of your apps and
you can continue hitting the tab key to
cycle through them and even hit the q
key to close them and finally let go of
the command key to enter into that app
while selecting text command a will
select all command c will copy and
command v will paste so i'd recommend
learning all of these shortcuts if you
want to be as productive as possible and
the best way to do this is by simply
holding down the command key within any
app to see a list of the shortcuts you
can use in that specific app which is
incredibly useful now in terms of the
quality of this keyboard i'm actually
very impressed because you get
traditional keys with an excellent
amount of key travel unlike the keys on
the smart keyboard folio for the ipad
pro which honestly don't feel that great
the only downside with this keyboard is
that because the ipad itself is smaller
than a full-size keyboard this means
that you obviously won't get a full-size
keyboard on this case so it might take
some time to get used to but once you do
it'll feel natural and because this
logitech keyboard case uses the smart
connector the keyboard is basically hard
wired to the ipad so every single
keystroke registers and it registers
quickly with no lag which is something
you can't say for bluetooth keyboards
same thing goes for the trackpad which
works better than i expected especially
after i turned off the trackpad inertia
setting and increased the scrolling
speed so overall i'm extremely impressed
with this keyboard case especially since
it's only 10 dollars more than the
version of this keyboard that doesn't
get a trackpad and it's half as
expensive as apple's magic keyboard case
for the ipad pro as for the downsides
there were a couple of times where the
cursor just wouldn't show up so i simply
had to reconnect the keyboard to get it
to show back up but hopefully firmware
updates should fix this soon i also
noticed that if you pick up the ipad and
you let the keyboard hang down it can
actually fall off if it swings backward
so keep that in mind and my only other
complaint is how much heavier and
thicker it makes the ipad but to be
honest you're getting a really solid
case in a keyboard with a trackpad so i
don't think that other keyboard cases
will be much lighter than this but other
than that i think logitech did an
absolutely great job on the combo touch
keyboard case and i would recommend
anyone looking to buy a keyboard case to
100 percent spend the extra cash on a
built-in trackpad case because if adding
a physical keyboard essentially doubles
the value of the ipad by itself then
adding a trackpad on top of that takes
it to a whole new level turning what
used to be a basic tablet into a
full-fledged budget laptop replacement
and one thing i know for sure is that
there will soon be cheaper bluetooth
keyboards with built-in trackpads coming
to amazon but i fully believe that
spending a hundred and fifty dollars on
this keyboard case is worth it for the
build quality the design and the
excellent reliability of the smart
connector you won't regret it if you
enjoyed this review tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
and if you haven't already seen our six
month review of this 10.2 inch ipad you
can check it out by clicking that button
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]